hello my name is mathias vom date up
and dance video like to show you can
easily great frequency table online the
state of what is frequency
frequency table created the static
display absolute relative frequency
the frequency table already sat
frequency table for example shows you
how often the  male and female value
cycle news
so lay it is simple example us no
people what is the answer your senses
frequency frequency two high
frequency and thundered frequency free and told
you have nine people asked so and here
education to present the great one click
& cable after work and complex data and
cockpit example vodka brands
when invalid value added value and i
liked commented on the video on youtube channel